what is happening there reject nation
okay this is a long time coming because
this video has been out for a while and
i heard koi was featured in it too so i
was like we gotta wait till koi is here
to properly experience this gom films
george my good friend he did a dub of a
video he took a video of what's
that he made a dub out of it and i have
the title right here i'm unprepared for
this i know nothing except that's entity
yeah he's never even seen a gom films
video i i don't youtube often i'm sorry
it's not about him it's about me he does
dubs of like interviews from like chris
evans tony mcguire and he does like some
hilario they're they're so funny they're
so funny this is real rejects no
spider-man no way home board reaction
tub and i think he took footage of one
of our hawkeye episodes and then he uh
made a little video out of it i'm
honored and i've been telling him for
like weeks i'm gonna watch i'm gonna
watch it this week i'm gonna watch this
week and now i'm going out here like
we're gonna finally do this let's do it
spiderman is done so what do you think
we should react to
how does he know how we
feel any thoughts
i guess let's just watch whatever's on
tv yes
that's me
this is actually real though like this
was true check out that rain it's nasty
i'm sure everything is probably wet
it's wet because it rained
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i win this guys
day of shooting this evening um i'll
post them on the screen here these are
it
let's
get ahead of ourselves
[Music]
we're about to win the lottery
dude what is going on this is seriously
happening 69 dude you just need to find
a ball
i hope
you guys can forgive me
i would have done the same thing
oh hey let's watch this you know people
probably wouldn't believe that we've
only watched the first star wars insane
[Laughter]
incredible
[Laughter]
oh man what a twist guys honestly i'm so
happy we never got spoiled by this and
we experienced this all together yeah
dude
she deserves respect is it true
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i would have won a house so
now what do you want to see some kanye
west um you guys want to go upstairs and
play with our spider-man action figures
yes all right that's it peace out
[Music]
we're frauds we're all frauds
amazing so every reaction gets made we
have a stockpile of footage of us just
kind of going nuts at different times
ourselves yeah yeah yeah and then we
just get very excited
i don't like that he knows that much i'm
uncomfortable that our secret's been
revealed and now we're posting it it's a
little too how the sausage is made i uh
i definitely feel very exposed that he
knows that uh our fear was there and
here we are olivia messes me why are you
so loud
i just messaged her the video is the
center of the video
it's so good we've definitely been
quieter about authentic trailers we've
waited years for i i gotta see if george
is awake oh that's so good real time
reaction it's so late at night for him
he's hours ahead oh you're calling yeah
he's my friend i just i text people
leave no all right not not in a video
not in a video of course pick up
pick up george i know it's late and you
have a family oh he's got a family now
you got a family george
and i'm calling you like midnight your
time
but i gotta get all of us on camera
sorry mr phone call
oh george
family
george my friend
john say hi george hi coy oh hey oh hi
mark so george uh yeah it took us many
weeks to finally get around to it uh to
watch that reaction that that video you
made that dub because uh koi has finally
been able to be here after so many weeks
yeah this was uh this is amazing this is
hilarious this is so this is
so great and like i think you made a
perfect proof of us and
you exposed us fully yeah no i i'm
uncomfortable yeah like
i think george was honoring us his
intention but instead what he did was he
uh he got real he he was like this is
what they really think and this is how
they really behave this is how i really
feel they'll react to it again
the lottery that was so and then we just
moved on it just moved on
let's watch
the prices right
i'm so broken inside at the time we're
filming this is 9 something p.m so it's
past midnight for you i'm sorry for
calling so late but uh thank you buddy
this is uh so special uh thank you thank
you man
don't i hope your wife doesn't think
you're having an affair and that
number's safe
you're going to be in trouble
george lay this out see your buddy it's
for you
yeah that was i don't know about you but
come on dude
like that is so special and one of one
like what a unique experience to watch
you as someone else watches you dubbing
over you like what a thing it was such a
great parody of us because like i
thought he just isolated so well i
really like her sad john like it's like
john had a whole arc like john went on a
journey of like he was always the one in
the know and it always was it was
painful
like it was bad to know too much
better
painful to carry the burden of knowledge
capturing those faces of ours when we
don't we're not reacting to something
bigger but we're just listening or
listening these are some lessons
listening face reactions we also like
here we go from like one to ten like
especially when we get clipped down
highlights there's never like a five
like we're not casually involved in it
it's a one or four we just shoot our
faces
my favorite part is
because it never rains here it doesn't
rain here it might rain friday rain
day as we shot this and it was like the
first time in weeks and after before
that was the first time in months moon
night full moon this video reigned
and then what was the winning the
lottery and i just love how we just
don't start moving
we won and then we just moved forward
that we lost we lost because you forgot
to play oh that's right
i was laughing at there was so much i
was laughing at that i i missed i got
your subtext george i got you i missed
so much as i was laughing oh we'll be
back we'll watch it again thank you this
was uh
this was amazing thank you george here
uh yourdebomb.com the ultimate revealing
flattery
[Music]